in this video we're going to talk about
density in the context of area and the
simplest way of thinking about it is
density is going to be some quantity
per
unit area
so for example let's say
that i have a football field
right over here and i have another
identical football field right over here
now they have the same area
but if i have let's say
five people on this football field
actually six people on this football
field and i only have three people on
this football field the density of
people per average unit area or the
density of people i should say per
football field is going to be higher in
this left example so it's always going
to be quantity per area now that out of
the way let's do a worked example that
helps us understand this idea a little
bit better
so here we're told the town of
tigersville has a population density of
13 cats per square kilometer so they're
giving us the density let me write that
13
cats so the quantity is quantity in cats
per square kilometer that's the density
right over there the town is shaped like
a perfect isosceles trapezoid so it
looks something
like
this it's a perfect isosceles trapezoid
it's going to look something like that
with two parallel boundaries 12
kilometers apart so this distance right
over here is 12 kilometers one measuring
eight kilometers so this side over here
is eight kilometers the other is 16
that's the longer one over there
how many cats are in tigersville so they
give us the density here and they give
us i think enough information to figure
out the area and they want us to figure
out how many cats we have so what is the
quantity so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
well just as we said that density is
equal to quantity divided by area if we
multiply both sides of this equation by
area you get area times density
is going to be equal to
quantity
and we know the density it's 13 cats per
square kilometer and we can figure out
the area and then just multiply the two
so what's the area of this right over
here
well the area of a trapezoid is going to
be let me write it here area is going to
be 12 kilometers the height of the
trapezoid times the average of the two
the the two parallel sides i guess you
could say so the average of those so
it's going to be eight kilometers plus
16 kilometers
over two
so this is going to be equal to 12
kilometers
times 8 plus 16 is 24 divided by 2 is
12. so times 12
kilometers so this gives us
144 square
kilometers
now we know we have 13 cats per square
kilometer so let me do this here in
another color so if i multiply 13
cats
per
kilometer squared and i multiply that
times
this business right over here
times
144
square kilometers and you might also
notice that the units cancel out the
same way that variables might so that
cancels out with that you're going to
get 13 times 144 and the units that
you're left with is just cats so 144
times 13. 3 times 4 is 12 3 times 4 is
12 that gives us to 13 3 times 100 300
plus another 100 is 400
now i'm just going to multiply 144
essentially by 10 which is just going to
be 1440 and so if i add up all of that
together i'm going to jump down to here
i get 18
72. so this is 18
72
cats in total and we are done